so I take it the rights to limp Biskit
Snooki were too expensive and they're
already predicting their sin tally in
case you confused it with Berne Idaho
mullets were not in style in 1999 Jon
Favreau's at a New Year's party but
isn't picking up beautiful babies Tony
is a dick to nerds so this is basically
the same research that Oscorp did in the
amazing spider-man happy is addicted
genetically engineered super plants
giant holes on Tony's arm after the
injection and a miracle cloth wipes them
away so basically Tony built a bunch of
suits that can come to him as shown in
the final battle scenes so what's the
point in building the mark 42 and he
could just call up a suit from one of
the other 40 he wanted a suit that came
to him specifically in pieces seriously
iron patriot not sure if iron Captain
America or American Iron Man Joan Rivers
Tony and Colonel Rhodes discuss
important classified information in a
bar one of Paltrow happies too stupid to
know how to flip an iPad Tony's security
guard doesn't know how to use an iPad
but can research everything on the evil
guy in less than five minutes of finding
out about it when we suggests the iPhone
could take a distinguishable image of a
license plate from the entrance to the
parking lot while the car is moving a
shame black movie set at Christmas how
original
one a dick Tony Stark manages to change
the phone in front of him to a
significantly better phone just by being
in its presence when tony is sending a
holiday greeting to the Mandarin eeeh
sunglasses on but then in the next shot
from behind he doesn't have any glasses
on then they reappear in the next shot
he takes them off vertical video and I'm
just saying you're a terrible extra good
mic placement dude haha this guy only
brought a pen and a pad Tony Stark is
addictive phones cars pointed one way
when he gets in then leaves in the other
direction mm-hmm what are you doing huh
what's that over there
boobs tony is able to make an exact copy
of a crime scene that was not completely
photographed or sketched for an
international superhero and weapons
supplier Tony Stark seemed suspiciously
lacking in the security department I
don't remember what I had for breakfast
gluten
Tony Stark eats gluten free waffles yes
Tony great idea tell the bad guy exactly
where you live so he can come after you
actually after being the Iron Man for so
long shouldn't the bad guy already know
where he lives
nobody watches the US airspace for a
living notices these suspicious
unauthorized helicopters armed with
explosives making a dangerous beeline
straight for Iron Man's house the force
of the explosion would definitely kill
Tony when he hit the fucking concrete
wall man if only there was some kind of
protocol to activate all the other Iron
Man suits to spring into action where
the hell is shield Tony Stark was
underwater way longer than humanly
possible Jarvis uses Apple maps child
character represents the intended age
demographic which Athens stands leave no
need to be a pussy you better Tony is a
dick to kids Tony gives a dangerous
weapon to a little kid my boss is
working for the Mandarin former lover
turns out to be working for the bad guy
cliche dora the explorer' watch the only
enemy that actually threatens to defeat
Tony Stark is panic attacks discount
Halle Berry no one in this whole town
recognizes the most famous man in the
world how the hell did Killian soldiers
find Stark in the middle of nowhere
while the extremis soldiers can heat up
metal to new year liquid states their
clothing remains completely unaffected
ha I see Tony Stark went to the previous
school of running away from things not
even a half hour of screen time and he's
already better than Carl Grimes turning
paper upside down and it means something
else cliche last time I went missing if
I remember correctly you came looking
for me no that was the other roadie
discount Brian Austin Green this tattoo
villain kidnaps the heroes girl cliche
the time it takes for Tony's bulb
grenade to blow up down the hallway is
significantly longer than the one he
drops in the fountain now the gloves on
his right hand the electric glove is
made for his left hand as shown here Ben
Kingsley isn't Gandhi in this scene my
name is Trevor
surprise except it's stupid if Trevor is
an actor how come none of the members
from his previous productions he worked
on or any of the acting guilds he was
affiliated with can recognize him we
rule from behind the scenes I see
Killian went to the Miranda Tate School
of explaining one's entire plan to the
one person that could foil it before
actually killing them there's nothing in
either of Killians hands but when he
goes to shoot Maya that gun appears when
he raises his arm in the following shots
when he leaves the gun is gone again at
one point in the movie aldrich killian
spits fire out of his mouth completely
destroying a staircase however in the
final fight he never uses it once even
though it seems to be one of the most
powerful things he can do windows on Air
Force One are bulletproof
when Tony is in captivity and calls for
his mark 42 suit the suit tries
frantically to escape from the garage in
Tennessee once it finally escapes it
only takes a few minutes for the suit to
then reach him meaning it must have been
flying at something like 23,000 miles
per hour yet when Tony is saving the
people falling from Air Force One he
barely has the speed to reach all of
them in time Tony Stark's car changes
places during cuts chunky monkey chunky
monkey that's offensive to large people
falling from the sky honestly now
they're traumatized and offended what
are they screaming about they're getting
free skydiving at ain't cheap dramatic
slow-motion shot of people falling into
the water cliche the Iron Man suit gets
broken and smashed to pieces by a truck
it doesn't matter if Tony's in it or not
in the first movie the suit could take a
direct hit from a tank shell and Tony
shrugged it off like it was nothing
now a freaking truck can destroy it at
that time the house party protocols
house party protocol features neither
kids nor play yeah that seems like
protocol leave the president chained up
in a fully working Iron Man suit and a
place where you can easily escape the
amount of Iron Man suits is too damn
high badass gigantic suit making a an
awesome entrance wrecks everything in
its path and then used to support the
tower seriously oh yeah that's awesome
give me a suit okay oh I'm sorry they're
they're only coated to me yeah and
pepper and Killian
Iron Man suits are racist seriously
where are the Avengers
even if Stark didn't call them for help
you think Nick Fury or Captain America
himself would maybe have stepped in when
the President of the United States gets
kidnapped by a
ornery fire-breathing terrorists when
the president is wearing the iron
Patriot armor at the end he's trapped
and can't do crap and yet when Rhodey
puts it on it becomes functional why are
the Iron Man suits one-size-fits-all
no matter who put it on throughout the
whole movie it seems to fit Bond villain
thought dead but not really dead cliche
Killians not fighting in his own Ironman
suit in the climax damn missed the
trifecta shocking Gwyneth Paltrow
survived scene not really all that
shocking before being captured pepper
decided to pick out a bra that was 100%
fire and extremists proof maybe she
bought it at the same place Bruce Banner
picks up his shorts pepper rips off a
suits arm and then uses the repulsor
without a power source at the end of the
movie pepper can instantly shoot the
hand blaster from the Iron Man suit with
no experience at all damn it did Gwyneth
Paltrow just saved the fucking day scene
does not include a thermonuclear
lapdance stockholders Jarvis to blow up
all the suits and then taps his ears
though he had an earpiece even though he
has nothing in his ear but Jarvis still
heard him the clean slate protocol the
clean slate protocol that you can save
the girlfriend or this important
political character but not both
once movie would be a Dark Knight ripoff
if it wasn't already ripping off the
Incredibles so the armors all have
fireworks in them why didn't the suit on
Pepper's arm explode shouldn't I mean
the Eagle armor should be destroyed too
and the tower should be falling down on
them police take Trevor into custody
instead of Shane black
Tony gets the shrapnel out of his chest
now he just has to worry about living
his life with the gaping hole where his
sternum used to be yeah it's totally
cool to just hurl your leftover
machinery into the ocean Tony is a dick
to the environment Iron Man films still
yet to talk about Tony's alcoholism Tony
is driving an Audi r8 e-tron which is an
electric car electric cars do not make
that noise
no ac/dc in an Iron Man film way to rip
off the Nolan Batman trilogy with the
title of the movie showing up at the end
especially since Iron Man 1 & 2 didn't
do this the movie says oh you stay for
the end credits scene
that's 20 minutes what are you gonna do
to me you'll see your zip tied to a bed
you sir truly are mr. incredible you
know I was right to idolize you I always
knew you were tough but tricking the
probe by hiding out of the bones of
another super Oh
You Know Who I am you don't know where I
am I don't know who you are I don't know
what you want level position has just
been vacated so which of you fine
gentlemen would like to join our team